Good morning, Paul.
Morning, how you doing?
Something pretty good about you.
I'm alright.
Hi, Paul.
Amit, how are you?
Good.
How have you been?
I've been alright.
Great, good stuff. Are you coming to build it?
I'm trying.
I'm registered.
I'm trying to make sure we're good with it on our end.
That's great. Once you're registered, you're coming. Yeah. Now you're registered, so great. I think the hotel and other things will be in place for you.
Yeah, hopefully.
That that becomes a little messy to our sense, so it's good news that you are registered and the hotel is booked.
and I'm sure Paul will be excited to meet you in person.
Yeah, should be good.
So, I'm not 100% yet, but yeah, I'll probably know within a week.
Morning, Lee.
Sure.
We're gonna hold on to hope.
Heidi.
Dipon.
As your week.
All right.
Relatively busy.
You extended for the weekend?
Yes.
Well, we're.
But hours away, mere hours away at this point.
Tired.
Fair enough.
Well, no, you're not getting Kris today, probably. He's traveling.
And Luis and Linden is going to be joined.
I hope so.
I was going to say, this is...
Otherwise, it'll be a very short call.
I was gonna say, this is predominantly to make sure that they have what they need and are getting what they need from the team, so...
If they're not available, let's make sure we're following up with them.
I know Lewis had something to bring up, but I'm not sure what it was.
Let's give a few minutes and if they're going to join.
I think till the time they start, probably I can check regarding Aman, how he is doing.
Doing good? He's on leave right now. He's doing fine.
Yes.
Yeah.
That's it, yeah.
a new responsibility that you're going to add.
Is they get to learn new things, you know, more excited to work the AI thing, so...
Have anything that you have planned?
Yeah, it's not it's not clear yet what our cells are going to look like on that side.
sales director in Florida and myself are working on fleshing that out for a couple of our customers. If we end up selling a significant amount of the AI offering, then it would be feasible to have them start doing some stuff in that area. But it would still mostly be administrative work on the portals and platforms for it and making sure people are getting what they need.
Okay.
Um...
There will be AI things. It's not the next like week or two.
Yeah.
We're we're we're working on on some things.
So based on my conversation, Paul, with Aman, what I understand that he's also looking for career progression in terms of what more he can do, even on the technology side, right? So I've been doing this for quite some time now, and he's more inclined towards owning more responsibilities.
Mhm.
which is what we expect from our engineers and it's great to see that he's inclined towards it. He's also applying for promotions internally. He's been through the written test and he's cleared it. Now the next step would be towards the technical examination that will take place whenever he opts for.
once he's ready. So yeah, I think he's making a lot of progress in terms of learning new technologies and getting promotions internally into the technical side of things. And at the same time, he was more inclined towards what more can I own in terms of roles and responsibilities and
Okay.
Of course, the technology side.
Sure, so the team he's part of with Luke obviously is essentially stack management, right? They have a handful of products they're responsible for. That's auto elevate, quick pass, patching, the RMM, things like that. Within that scope, there's plenty of responsibility. There's...
Mhm.
Yeah.
tons of growth. It's maybe not targeted specifically at high-end technical work, but it's definitely organizational and managed services knowledge and work and responsibility that I'm fine with him getting more and more involved in. And I know that's the plan as far as I'm concerned with going forward is as I move more into the AI things and get dragged in more management stuff, I'm...
Mhm.
slowly giving more and more of that to Luke and Aman, which is essentially his team member, right? So sure, Aman reports to me, but he's mostly working through Luke at this point. And that ideally would be take more and more of the stack over, get more governance involved on stuff like IT glue and quick.
pass, not will of it, and not just being, hey, install it, make sure it's there, but change management structure as far as what's its product roadmap, how is it implemented, where is the value, and making those suggestions, recommendations, and keeping up on the forefront of those offerings. So there's room for growth. There's definitely growth there. It's just not maybe.
Mhm.
high-end like server networking work, right? It's more targeted goals work of Ed learning how to interact with other divisions of the company and take over more and more of what the technicians are using, both on the IT side and ultimately on the print side.
Yeah.
Mhm.
as we're getting, my side's getting a little more involved on the print side of the business, which is the legacy is much larger side of the business, because they use like Service Now, eAutomate, Agent Dealer, which are pretty big piece of software. I'm sure you guys are familiar with eAutomate at least. And we're going to be getting into some of that as well. And Aman would be.
Yeah.
Kip.
involved in that. It's just a question of how much growth do we need to see and how quickly are we going to transition some of those responsibilities to them without overburdening them. Because right now they have a finite list of responsibilities and it's kind of hard already to keep up. And as Lewis and Kristen, their teams make progress cleaning up the other side of things.
Yeah.
It eases things on my side of things too. So eventually they'll be able to wrap their hands around more of that stack and take more of that responsibility and that impetus to drive more value out of it. That's where the roadmap is as far as Aman is concerned, as far as my team's growth on that end, at least as far as that part of the team. So if that's of interest to him.
Mm.
Great, that's fine. If this is a foreshadowing that he's going to want to move in a different direction, that's good to know. Not a lot I can do about that.
I think it's...oh, sorry, I don't know.
Yeah, no, I understand.
No, Ali, complete your thoughts, sorry.
No, all I was going to say is I think it's worth that discussion, right, as a with Aman directly. So Paul Aman Thakur, sounds like it's worth us with, you know, the four of us, the three of us at Amit, you know, having a dedicated discussion to.
at least aligning on what the path would look like clearly on the Milner side, Paul. And then you and Aman, maybe if you could collaborate on a discussion directly with Aman to talk it through and just give him some food for thought.
Yeah, that's fun.
Yeah, because we don't, I don't know that we have, and I mean, Aman and Amit keep me honest here, but I don't know that we have definitive clarity on this being foreshadowing of a wanted change away from anything you're describing, right? Because I don't think we knew.
what it was going to look like from your perspective and on your side. So I think this is more of a, let's start the conversation so that we can see how this unfolds and bring it to Aman and make sure that we're all working together to make it win, win, win.
Yeah, the chief issue being is what he's doing is critical. And as he's doing the work, it's not like I can displace what he's doing. We have to find ways to make it more efficiency so that he can move into better responsibilities and bigger things without losing what he's doing.
Right.
Yep.
be floundering to get results in both areas instead of just the first one trying to get it under control. So we see great results from him as is, but I'm, so you see where I'm coming from.
Absolutely.
I'm happy to say, hey, yeah, take these other two things and run with them and make them great again. But he's not going to have the bandwidth to do that without lagging on the things he's already supposed to be doing, where we already have a large amount of backlog work too. So, but I'm open to the conversation. Let me know.
Yeah, absolutely.
I don't want to eat up more of Louis this time. It's his call, really.
No.
Yeah, no problem. Well, hey, Linden loose. How you doing?
Hey, Aman, everything's going well, you?
Good, yeah, yeah. So the competition is still going on or?
Oh no, no, we've settled. At this point, we're just gonna continue the madness.
Yeah.
Shh.
I was going to say, feels very much like just a, hey, let's keep this thing going.
Right, good. Yeah, I think we covered, but Paul's, I think we'll start with the Lois Linden. How is everything going?
Individually, as a team.
Ohh.
Everything's going okay. I mean, Paul did mention in regards to the MDE side. And so I guess I can bring a little bit of information that is going to be transitioning at some point. Right now, before we green light anything, we want to make sure that we have
all their SOPs, processes, and everything in line before we green light it. And we were also in talk of utilizing most likely Janad to assist in this area as well. But we're slow transitioning the MDE, the support side.
to...
start handling their remote requests and as far as the printers to that degree. And so we're working with one person, his name's Dustin. We're going to be transitioning him over to IT support. We're going to be absorbing his work, which is really just printer installs, driver installs.
setting up certain things like scanning emails, scanning folders. It's all printer related stuff. It is remote stuff. It has nothing to do with the field perspective, sending someone on site. That eventually will come down the path at some point, but right now we're just going to start in a small section.
and then iron it out, make sure we got all our SOPs and everything taken care of, and eventually expand out. But just as far as, hey, what is coming on the path probably in the next two weeks or so is, yeah, we're absorbing, guiding Dustin over into the IT support team.
We're going to be absorbing his work as far as his workload. He doesn't take inbound calls.
So...
At most, what he does take as far as calls is...
The Milner team, the field team that actually gets sent out to the locations, will actually be calling him up to, hey, can you remote into this computer, assist with this printer install, which then relieves the field tech to go do whatever they need to do for the most part.
But with that said, he's not part of any actual call queue. He does, like Paul mentioned, use E automate. And when if the conversation of, hey, are you taking that call is said, you know, the way, you know, I assume you have E automate experience, but.
for the most part, they call every ticket a call. You know, it's a service call, you know what that says. So we're going to be taking that workload. And typically, as far as right now, the workload Monday through Friday on an average day is about 7 calls or 7 tickets per day that would get generated.
And so on a busy day, we can just double that for, you know, with that said. But it being printer installations related and all remote printer installations related, you know, we're not expecting too much difficulty as far as dealing with the actual
point of the service call. The only thing that we're going to see as far as needing to iron out in regards to the whole ordeal is the process itself. We're going to need people that are going to have access to their e-automate and then develop as far as how we're going to interact with those.
tickets in eAutomate and from there we're also designating a few people, Janad being one of them. We wanted to test out one ITBD person along with two Miller people that's going to be involved and then Dustin who we're absorbing into this process.
He's still going to be assisting as well. We're going to be relying a lot on him in regards to what is currently going on. So that way we can create SOPs and get that out. And then eventually, once all four of them, along with Linden, Kelvin, and I, work together to get everything ironed out, we'll expand.
And that to the rest of the ITBD team, ITBD team, and also the rest of the Milner team, so that way, you know, everyone will start assisting and pitching in to be able to take care of that, but as far as the workload, it's not extreme. The what the work is related to is not gonna be, you know, that big either, because, like I said, it's just...
remote printer installs and assist. So we're, you know, with that said, just FYI, that's coming on the path.
And Lewis, what's the average handling time of those calls slash tickets?
As far as what we initially found, the turnaround time is roughly around 15 minutes. So, and that's on average. And like, because usually the, like I said, he doesn't take calls. There's no inbound queue of any type that goes to him.
Okay.
So he's mostly going to be making outbound calls, and typically it's just assisting people with installing a printer. So not all printers, unfortunately, are made the same to that degree. But the point is,
Yeah.
Ashish.
be more clients with that typical turnaround should be roughly around 15 minutes on average. You know, with that said, and most of that really is just trying to get connected to the device that they want the printer on and downloading and installing the driver, you know, at that point. Those are the two keys that's really going to take most of the time.
configurations and things like that usually is the quickest part as far as dealing with that.
Thank you, Louis.
Yeah, yeah, sound like a very good plan, you know, so we definitely, whatever the support do you think that need from our side, yeah, definitely let us know. I think I'll check about how Warney and Abdul, especially how they're doing, Linden, Lewis.
In terms of current performance, they're adapting well. They're still, I would say they're still getting familiar with our processes, especially due to the current changes. We made some newer changes in the processes, so they have to adopt to the SLPs. We have seen a change in how they're working.
Yeah, that's right.
Kip.
the tickets. We did want to bring attention to, we are seeing like longer calls for certain techs. So like definitely pay attention to the escalation SOP that we have and if you don't have it, we can provide it. We're seeing a lot of calls that should.
Like they're taking like an hour and a half and there's no resolution at the end and they're escalating it. If they escalate it sooner, we'll have a happy customer and then that ticket can get serviced the correct way and ask for escalated resource. So that's something I'll bring to your attention.
Sure, and is it is it limited to few engineers from ITBD or is it throughout the team, Linden?
Definitely, yeah.
Uh, I would say a few. It's not, it's not a lot.
Okay, okay. Anyone in specific that we need to be talking to?
Ohh.
Oh.
It would, I would say for now, I would probably just put attention on Palak and Vernie.
Right, being that Bernie is a newer resource, he, I'm pretty sure he has to get a little bit more familiar.
Ala Convert.
Yeah, yeah, comparatively is the newest. Yeah, OK.
Kour.
I mean, any ticket that you have, probably, if you can share that, I'll definitely find those tickets, but if you have any other good example, or I can review and check with Vernie for the same.
Yeah.
Yeah, I'll look through and get with you on that one.
And how about?
Sure, yeah, and how about the about Khan and the weekend things? You seems to be improving the utilization, they're putting extra effort on on the weekend, especially.
Yeah.
Tickets, reviewing tickets, so we've seen a great change in that.
Good to hear that, yeah, and and if I like Palak still think she's still working right the full time, because the ongoing PTOs and upcoming video that we have to make sure that we have coverage during that shift, so she's doing the regular shift.
Okay.
Any other changes that you are planning or that you have already planned to make the process better?
Uh...
If I'm not mistaken, Lewis, we were doing the auto-assigning for, I guess, the round robin for the tier ones, which would include ITBD resources. We've changed it. We're now including the tier twos. They'll still be getting tickets, but...
Pretty much any ticket in the open status, they should be able to work. And as far as the customer hate, just for this time, once if they get those tickets, escalate it to tier 2.
Okay, yeah, and about Maxwell and Whaler, I mean, I had to connect with Ruben last week, you know, the few conversation that I had regarding their tickets and link performance and everything, so they are also aligned. I know if they have a time to make sure they are looking at the Helpdesk ticket.
And if there is no action event to probably they can review the ticket, see if anything they can email the customer or put their notes, see if they can handle on the weekend and the weekday. So they are line on that side. Yeah, performance wise, yeah, I mean, I'm keeping close eye about both their performance ticket and everything. So they are on track.
So then I personally connected with Ruben over the email too, to make sure that, you know, he's aware that, yeah, he said as of now they're doing good. And I think for the CSAT probably, just for your reference, he's going to fill the survey for both.
So yeah, I will change that on the next month for rest people going to be Lewis and for Valor and Maxwell is going to be Ruben.
Right, I think I...
So Luis, do we need to change the meeting times to allow Ruben to be on these calls?
Make any changes here?
I mean, because his schedule is 8 to 5 in the morning, yeah, it's going to be rough to, he's third shift, you know, to that degree. It's kind of like trying to get Maxwell or Valor in this thing. It's like, you know, it's pretty rough to do that.
Dipon.
Oh, okay. Yeah.
Yeah.
But, yeah.
Yeah, no, I understand. All right, in that case, we'll keep it this way.
That's true.
But Ruin do connect over the email, so we frequently exchange email, you know, check the performance and everything, anything, any concern, anything, so yeah, he keep posted as in the team.
Risk it. I will share my screen then to our agenda.
Yeah.
Alright, let me know if you can see my screen.
Thank you, Kour. So we have this is for the last week and again, welcome to our weekly service review meeting.
So there's no change in the agenda. Everything remains same. We already checked how things are going at the moment, how the team is doing.
These were the few highlights for last week. So yeah, the ticket creation SOP has been already shared with the team, so everyone is aligned. I will do a recheck about the escalation process document, so make sure they are following that too. So the other process that you implemented about the phone system, so the team is fully aligned with that too.
Performance, if you talk about the overall utilization for the team for month of May, 62%.
And your C sets, yeah, thank you, Luis, for giving the access. I mean, I get notification every day, every hour, whenever there is any C set that customer filled in, so I'm getting clear visibility about how they are doing, what feedback customer is giving, so I don't see anything negative or amber as of now, so all are positive for the entire team.
You know, a specific check for Abdur and Vernie, so the few I get for last week and till yesterday.
And just FR in regards to the CSAT, sometimes it's a false report, meaning they selected the wrong option, but said they did a good job, they were great, they were patient, they were this and that. And what we do is we go back to that specific one and change it to the correct one. So.
Yeah.
I do have the ability to correct what was mistakenly put in.
Okay, yeah, thank you for the information.
So these were the action tracker item that we have from our last meeting. And so KP, we already discussed the team is already aligned. Maxwell and Weiler replacement has been completed since they are doing good and performance has been improved. I think Mehmet C said, Luis, I think I emailed you also.
last week about you probably you filled up the survey for the rest team. I think few maybe pending it or it's already done. Paul I think already submitted.
Ohh, we're still working on that, uh, the last one, CSAT.
And...
Yeah, yeah, thank you for that, Pete, yeah.
So, just one thing for my clarity and apologies, Aman, to interrupt you. So, Lewis, we talked about the possibilities of replacing Max and Wailer. Now, what I understand based on my interaction with Aman Thakur, right, that...
They're moving in line with the expectations that we had. And at this moment, we see them fit for purpose. And we're not going ahead with a replacement. Is it something that we're all aligned with?
Yeah, we were, you know, putting them on pretty much on monitor. It seems like now they have improved in actually, you know, doing things, keeping themselves busy, utilizations going up. We're seeing all that now. So as long as, yeah, they continue down this path,
Yeah.
I don't see a problem with keeping them on.
Mhm.
Yeah, awesome. Yeah, I just wanted to be clear and make sure that we are perfectly aligned in terms of what we are observing versus what you're observing your site as well. And these things in terms of monitoring the performance and ensuring that they are falling in line and they always deliver what they're expected to would be a priority from our site. So yeah.
Thank you.
Thank you, Amit.
Okay.
Do you have an understanding, Aman, which all C sets are currently pending, so that we can just walk Lewis through it?
Thanks for.
David Handy.
Yeah, I have to check. Maybe Maxwell and Will, Ruben already filled, but I think it's for the rest of the team, except Aman, Abdul, Vernie.
So...
Yeah, so we do have for Maxwell, Baylor, and Aman from Paul. So I think it is a complete core Helpdesk team, Lewis, and Linden that we are currently left with.
Sunny.
Will be.
Nice, thank you. Next one, the PTO. So, we have already discussed the PTO and engineer took PTO as per the plan. Junaid is on PTO. Kundan has upcoming PTO. Aman is also on PTO. Vernin Abdul process training that we discuss, you know.
What?
So that has been also completed.
More for the performance and so I just put the two week of data to just compare how things are going and what are the improvement that as a team that they are making and individually as well. So again, Javid, if we talk about 24th to May 30th, so overall his utilization 60.
Sorry, 76.88%. So next, but 31st to June 6th, 70% closed 42 tickets. Kundan, yeah, which he made good progress, 52%, then second week 50%.
Maxwell, 88%, then the last week, 90%. Wheeler is again close to Maxwell, where 88.93, and the last week, 74.83%. Let me know any question that you have for anything, any numbers, Linden, Lewis, Paul.
Warning again, if we compare prior to May 24th, he was somewhere around 30, 32%, but now 42% to 44%. Same goes for Abdul, which made really good progress because I do remember prior to 24th of May, his overall utilization was around
31%. He was out for some PTO as well. Aman again doing pretty fantastic job, 96.53% and then 96% for the last week. Any question for any of the numbers?
One of the things, Linden, let us know if you're aligned. I mean, we were really concerned about Kundan doing the weekend shift and about his utilization, and it's good to see that he is able to clock at least 50%, which we needed, right, him to progress further from where he was.
Anything else that he can do, any suggestions or any recommendations that he may have in addition to what he's already doing? Because we see that there is a shift in the right direction.
For further suggestions, I honestly will have to look like off the top. We like I've we found.
areas where he can assist. If there's anything else, we'll have to look in further, see if he can, he's equipped with those skills.
Sure.
Yeah, absolutely. Because we are continuously working in the background to make sure that they are clocking the expected billable hours, if, of course, if they have the workload. And Kundan has shown the inclination towards doing it, and he's taking that interest and is pushing himself. So.
It's great to see that, you know, he's moving the right direction, but what will be really helpful is understanding what else so that we can start empowering him with the right skill set if it is not there.
Yeah.
Perfect. Back to you on.
Thank you. I think one more thing I added in the deck, but I think what I'm building something which is going to really help for us as a whole team, which is going to us, what we do, I think probably you're aware, the practice that we, I follow here to do a board review for the engineer where I individually check their ticket, review their tickets, note their.
troubleshooting step that they are following. So based on that, I'm in the process of creating a compiled data of for overall the board that they manage, which include their ticket health, which include their tickets note, email response, reopen ticket.
escalation rate and SLA compliance, average resolution time, and of course the first touch and SLA breach. Based on that, what is going to calculate the overall score of the ticket held and overall score of all the board. So yesterday I was checking that.
Just, you know, have not finished yet, but 90% has been completed. His overall score out of 100 was eighty-five percent, so which is really good when it comes to for all the seven word that they monitor.
So I'll definitely share those in upcoming service calls. So give us some more visibility where we can improve what all things we can work more effectively and improve those things as well.
Great, I think that's what I have from my side. Anything from your side, Linden, Luis, Paul?
The.
Mommy.
Sounds good.
Awesome!
Thank you, Lee, anything from you?
Nope, just glad to hear things are moving in the right direction and exciting stuff to hear about the pilot. I will happily help wherever it makes sense.
So, think.
Sure.
We will probably circle back late next weekly on the contract stuff.
OK, sure, so.
People are out of town, so yeah.
Yeah, no worries. Sounds good. I'll let Natalie know.
And Paul, you will connect with Aman once he's back next week about the additional stuff that we were discussing.
All right, yeah.
Sure. Do you guys want to put messaging around it or figure out internally what he actually wants to do first? I'm happy to talk to him. I talk to him every week, so it's fine.
Yeah.
Yeah, I was Kip.
Yeah, we, we, people.
I was going to say, yeah, I was going to say, let's give Paul some greater context. If that doesn't require a phone call, great. But if it does, let's tag him for a little bit of time and make sure that going into that discussion, we're all on the same page as far as what our understanding is so that we can.
Make sure, like I said, we're always looking for the win-win-win here, right? So, should be working toward that.
Right, and I think I think it exists. I think the only the only caveat may be that it might not be timely enough.
Mm.
because there's no clear timeline, right?
Understood, understood.
It's kind of like Maxville, right? I got ideas.
Yeah.
But ideas is ideas.
All right, thanks y'all.
True, true.
Thank you, Paul. Thank you.
Ohh.
Or I think.
Linden, thank you, Lewis. Thank you.
See all that.
Right, take care. Have a good day then, everyone.
Cheers, bye.
Blake.